Thank you.
And my co-presenter as
well, John, is here.
He will not be presenting because.
He can't be bothered, I guess.
Pardon?
is this better?
Yeah he works for the Department
of Ed, and we work together in.
John works for the
Department of Education
and we work together
in Chi Square lab.
So that's about us.
So I'm going to set the context.
And by the way, this talk isn't
actually I teach data science,
but this talk is not about
teaching data science.
It's about using data
science to teach.
That's sort of the
essence of what
we do in learning analytics.
We collect data from
educational interactions
and then we analyze that
and try to provide feedback
to instructors.
And the story here
is, as we all know,
there was a pandemic
in Argentina.
We went into full
lockdown in March of 2020,
and then that meant
that all instructions
needed to be online in a hurry.
Since we're in the
Southern hemisphere,
this actually
coincided pretty much
with the beginning
of the semester,
so we didn't have to
do it mid-semester.
But what happened is
that everyone started
to teach using Zoom or any
kind of video conferencing
system that was
available, and we
found that less than half
the students actually
had access to a laptop.
So in practice, they were
going to follow the course
on a device on an
Android forum, typically.
And the so what we wanted
to do and this is something
that we worked on
before, is to help
them create, help instructors
create a feedback
loop because as Kelly
mentioned in her talk,
there is a lot of
nonverbal communication
that goes on when you
actually meet face to face.
That's part of the
reason we're all here.
And you lose that.
You lose some of
it, at least when
you do video
conferencing, especially
if the class is a big
class with 100 students
or something like that.
So what we set out to do
was to mitigate some of this
by creating a tool
to provide feedback.
So the students could provide
feedback to the instructor.
And we did three
iterations of this.
One was slapped
together very quickly
because we were in a hurry
and I think less than a week.
And then we did, called
out the emergency alpha
and then we did a proper
alpha version in April.
And then we did what I
would call a beta version
in August of 2021.
So for the start of the, that
semester and the first one
we did in Shiny using a
package called Shiny mobile,
and then we hooked
it up to a back end.
And we, we have a package
called cognitoR
that allows for password
protection of Shiny apps
that we used.
It's available on CRAN
if you want to use it,
and then we distributed
that as a PWI.
And this is what it looks like.
So essentially the
two on the left there,
the two icons are just links.
to ah, Shiny apps, one
for the instructor and one
for the student and
they have a login
and that's handled by Amazon.
And then we have a
really easy questionnaire
with some, some questions.
One of them was
about connectivity
because it turned out
to be important in this
context and then there's two
open ended questions there.
You know, what did you
learn in this class
and what would you
like to have reviewed?
And this goes back
and gets analyzed,
and we use R for that.
And then we provide feedback
to the instructor on, you know,
the student feedback is
summarized and provided back
to the instructor.
And this is the same
package Shiny mobile
it provides, provides
the interface items that
look look good on a cell phone.
So and this is a completely.
You know, completely
reasonable way
of putting a Shiny
app on a cell phone.
It works.
It updates very quickly.
It's very lightweight.
It's only a link and
it's cross-platform.
It works on an iPhone.
It works on anything
that can show a web page.
We did find, though,
some bandwidth issues
because if everyone
tries to log on to,
we publish this to shiny.io
if everyone tries to log on
at the same time to
provide feedback,
it actually crashes the server.
Now you can solve
that by, you know,
by throwing hardware at it,
but that's not really scalable.
So and, you know, I was
also a little uncomfortable
that this is not a native app.
You can't send people to
the Play Store or App Store
to get it.
So the second version,
we used a template
from the Android community
and there's several
of them floating around.
There's one that we have that
we used that you can see there
on the slide.
It's essentially a wrapper
that displays a web page,
but this one goes
on the Play Store.
And, you know, you need
to know a little bit of Java.
And if you hate Python, you
probably hate Java as well,
but it's like two lines.
So it's not that
bad and it's still
just a Shiny app in a wrapper.
So it's still not
really scalable.
And it will only work
for android, which
which is a slight drawback.
So this is a slide from one
of the instructors,
and this was what it looks like.
This is probably
a later iteration.
So she used this to
show her students,
her students, the feedback
that she was getting from them.
And show them that this
is actually useful.
And, you know,
what did we learn?
And as you can see, you know,
it's summarized in not a word
cloud format because
that wouldn't really
look good in on a device.
So we used some other.
Other tools there.
And we got research
results from this,
which show they were
quite encouraging.
And so the scale
here is 0 to 10.
That's how it's
graded in Argentina.
Anything below, so 4 is
the lowest passing grade.
So that part of the scale
isn't actually being used.
And so, you know, the.
Distributions are not normal.
And there were some
outliers like you could see.
So we, you know, we use
Kendall's for correlations
and then we use
ordinal regression
instead of linear regression.
And we found during simulation
that we could actually predict.
This is post hoc though,
but we had predictive power.
After just three weeks,
we could pretty much
tell which students were
going to finish the course.
And we got good feedback
from the instructors.
They said, you know,
this is actually useful.
Useful for us.
There are some issues.
Some of them are actually
mentioned in the last talk.
There's a lot of
linguistic models
that you can get access
to, but they are.
Typically either too
general or too specific
when you're teaching a class.
And the example here is
class in linguistics,
introductory linguistics, it's
often very specific vocabulary
that you have to learn
and that will always
sort of mess up the, the,
the statistical models
that have been trained
on, you know, a billion,
billion words
because this is you know,
these are words that you use
in two papers in your life,
and then you don't repeat them.
And then there is the issue
of Spanish versus English
that we actually saw
some in the last post.
We did most of this
in Spanish, obviously,
but we are also working
on an English language
version of the same.
And also, you know,
the modeling tools
and the tools for doing NLP
tend to be Anglo centric.
So so that became a bit
of an issue as well.
But I think we resolved.
Most of them.
And then we get to the beta
version, the one that's
out now, and that's
a true native app
in a framework called Flutter.
The programming
language is called Dart.
So we've sort of we've moved
the back end to the Google Cloud
Firebase system, and
now authentication
is done by Google.
And we have all the analysis
done by R with a Plumber API
for, you know, so that
the cell phone will.
Get its information from.
And then we have enhanced
content recommendations
because one of the
features of this system
is that if I'm
teaching statistics
and no one got the
standard error,
I may repeat that in class.
But if two people did not get
what a standard deviation is,
I may not want to waste
class time on that
and I can send them
over to, you know,
watch a video or something.
And we try to automate
some of that, which is
interesting for large classes.
So and then we did an
email interface as well.
By the way, this is a.
This is what it looks like.
Now you sign up with a QR
code, which is convenient.
If you're teaching online, you
can show the code on the screen
and they can copy it right away.
It's a little more
awkward if you're actually
watching it on a cell phone.
But, you know, it's also
sign on with one link
and it's authenticated
by Google and all.
And then we did
we used blastula
to send out an email
report to the instructor.
And this was also.
You know, sort of
a way to get over
what I perceive to be
dashboard fatigue, that people
don't actually go and
log into the dashboards.
They, you know, but if you
get it pushed into your email,
maybe you actually
consume the information.
But that turned out
not to be the case.
Once we did this,
we got this feedback
from one of the instructors.
And Cecilia and I are married.
So so this was not
this was a request that
was difficult to ignore.
And in fact, it turned
out to be impossible.
So we we're sort of full circle.
We came back to Shiny
again, hoping that at least we
have the instructors on Shiny,
which would be a small, smaller
percentage.
So perhaps this
is still scalable.
It would be a lot worse if the
instructor and 200 students
would have to access the
server at the same time.
So so this is an
example from her course.
And this is also an example
from the same dashboard.
See here.
So these are some
content recommendations
that the system came
up with for the course
that I've sort of assigned this
to these specific students.
That's an artificial
intelligence piece
that we are working on.
And that's what I had for you.
This is our contact info.
We're happy to answer
questions, both of us.
So thank you.